cyril que sort de la salle de bain tout
de suite ça fait deux heures que tu es
dedans homme et je suis pas content mais
j'ai mal d'amis mongel mais je m'en
moque
tu feras sengel chantal pour ma
chronique oh là bas celui-ci la bombe en
cinq minutes
bon bah voilà bien loin de tous nos
petits sauts d'america ils n'ont reçu de
griffoul dis moi dommage est une très
bonne nouvelle
on reçoit giboulées fatwa dîner ah non
je peux pas les verrez il y avait les
démâtages après deux mois que tu fais
avec ses couteaux mais je vais les
mettre à la cave pas pourquoi bat au
rythme où ça va on va pas tarder à
recevoir thomas une habile hors série
montpetit tajine je suis rentré là tu
rentres tu te dis donc
iñaki sous la douche là tu te manque de
mots que je pense que lyon sous la
douche
mais c'est ma mère un regard de la boxe
thaï voulait prendre une petite douche
ouais je viens même design chic je parle
de sa maman bonne douche benoit rlc
série il ya plus d'un gène serait plus
d'un gel douche et drôlement jeu de ta
mère non c'est le boxe thaï
ça concerne j'ai bien fait ça parce
semaine dernière j'ai fait croire que
kenji été ma cousine
à l'est rien à quoi